foreign
North Carolina what's up Brock
hey Dr John how are you today partying
dude what are you up to
oh nothing much just living the dream
when you when you figure out how to
teach that let me know because you're
gonna make a billion dollars
will do actually I'm running a scam here
at this podcast thing so it's pretty
awesome it's awesome so what's up dude
hey uh well first of all thank you so
much for taking my call
um I it means a lot yeah thank you for
calling man
well I I have some some things written
down so I don't ramble too much uh so
I'm just gonna read it to you if that's
all right let's do it let's do it
all right um I've always had a tendency
to uh take things very personally I've
always been a very sensitive person
uh for as long as I can remember I have
been afraid of people being angry with
me uh disliking me yelling at me not
wanting me around stuff like that
uh to put it simply I've I've always had
a very intense fear of getting in
trouble
um this causes me to have very low
self-esteem low self-confidence I feel
like I'm often annoying to people or
unreasonably weird uh
and I I tend to get very defensive uh
easily
this has been having an increasingly
negative impact in my personal and
professional life
how can I overcome this fear oh man
um that's I
I know this I know that was hard for you
to write down and it was especially hard
for you to say it out loud and
um I want to tell you I'm grateful for
you thank you for doing that okay that
was Brave okay
um
trying to think where to start
do you have any I mean you pull that
drawstring all the way to when you're a
little one
um
who is did you have people watching over
you like a hawk
uh I did yeah
um my my dad was
kind of well he was emotionally abusive
uh towards my mom and my my sister and
I've been told to me as well though I
don't remember anything and so my mom
was was very
um
I think sometimes she she may have
overcompensated to make up for that
so your fear of stepping out of line one
millimeter your body's right it's not
lying to you
is seeing the consequence of getting out
of line
right
yeah and it's seeing the consequence of
getting out of line from somebody who
was supposed to look you in the eyes and
put their hands on both sides of your
face and tell you every single day of
your life God I'm the luckiest person in
the world that I get to be your mom or
dad
right
yeah
so
at the at the outset of this I want to
applaud your body for working properly
it knows what happens it's seen it
happen to a little kid and it will be
damned if it's gonna happen to an adult
and so you are on high high alert
tripwire alert
for any sort of way that either a you
have you're out of line
right you're a little bit off the center
or even more difficult and I would say
more maddening is your body's highly
tuned to other people thinking you might
be off
yeah because when you're a kid if you're
I'm just gonna make up something you're
pouring cereal and you're five and
you're learning how cereal works right
it all comes flying out of the out of
the bag out of the box you know and you
get two Cheerios on the counter
big whoop but if you grew up in certain
households somebody will get down close
to your face and say what kind of stupid
and disgusting can't even pour
cereal
and so you're not actually off center
somebody else perceives you to be is
that is that ring true a little bit
yeah definitely it does okay
so I want you to at first at the
beginning here make peace with your body
it's doing its job
you got hit before it's not getting hit
again okay
the second thing is
is if this continues much longer it's
going to drive you mad it's going to
kill you
and I don't say that metaphorically I
mean it's going to have issues with your
blood pressures can have issues with
cognitive functions can have issues with
sleep it's gonna have issues with making
relationships fair enough
yeah definitely okay so you hear me say
this a lot on this show it's especially
applies to you
the things that kept you safe as a kid
are going to destroy your adult life and
so he's got to get a handle on them okay
and the thing we have to know about
anxiety is the more we avoid something
the stronger that anxiety response
becomes I mean because it means it's
winning it's doing its job it's like oh
and I do this he hides awesome I'm gonna
do this louder right and so you've been
doing it for so long now your boss sends
you that email at 3 30 on a Friday it's
like hey can you swing by my office boom
you're in full fight or flight because
you're getting fired and that freaking
boss can't believe am I right
yeah that yep 100 and that boss could
have just y'all could have just gone to
lunch and he told you how awesome you
are and giving you a raise and he's like
hey swing by at 3 30. can you come by
real quick doesn't matter it's Off to
the Races because every time it restarts
it restarts it restarts or restarts
um yeah
so here's what we have to do
oh man let's see here
I'm gonna use a word that I hate using
because it makes you it's gonna make you
feel like I'm being dismissive of you
and it's gonna instantly make you think
of like some fat guy with a beard
sitting crisscross applesauce on a cloud
okay
the path forward here for you is mindful
and I don't mean meditation although
that may help what I mean about mindful
is
is consciously catching your body when
it spins up on you
and asking yourself the question out
loud
what am I afraid of right now
okay what is my body trying to keep me
safe from
from him oh I'm good I'm good
what is my body trying to keep from her
yeah she is abusive I'm gonna stop being
in a relationship with her
see what I'm saying and what we're going
to try to do is create a gap between
we're going to spend the rest of our
lives trying to build a gap between that
stimulus our body gearing up for War and
what we actually do about it
ah
I'm gonna take a deep breath drop my
shoulders
and I'm gonna consciously slow walk
through my boss's office
I'm gonna consciously do it even though
my body's like Ron get down there right
now I'm gonna consciously slow walk till
I get there
I'm gonna sit down and say how's it
going man I'm gonna feel my body the
whole time trying to get anxious on me
and keep telling myself this guy's safe
this guy's safe this guy's safe now can
I ask you a hard question
often people who grew up in a um
pressure cooker
create Secret Lives
and they become extraordinary performers
are there things in your life that if
they came to light
would be highly embarrassing
um or get you fired or or be something
that you would not want to explain
uh yeah I would say so okay
I would sit down with a counselor and go
right into those
okay because the other thing your body
knows is if you're carrying I call it an
anxious life but if you're carrying
secrets that if they got out it would be
over your body has a hyper-invested
interest and nobody finding out about
the secrets
if you owe a hundred thousand dollars in
student loans
and you have a boss that's calling you
into office on Thursday it knows if you
do get fired it's all she wrote It's
Over
you're not gonna eat you're gonna lose
your house you're gonna lose your car
you're gonna you're gonna the
government's gonna garnish your wages
and your Social Security and when you
get like all these things are gonna
happen right so if you don't owe anybody
any money
that Friday phone call or that Friday
email that you get you swing by like
okay
if he fires me that'll suck and I'll be
mad and I'll have my feelings hurt and I
sure like this job but
I'm not destitute you see the difference
there yeah definitely and so
um
it's about creating a non-anxious life
and those things that if they came to
light
you gotta deal directly with those
because I'm gonna say that they were
initially they're an outgrow an
outgrowth of that childhood but now
they're choices that you're making
is that fair
yeah yeah
how hard are they going to be to deal
with
uh I think
some of them are going to be
easier than others
um give me an example
oh boy uh
let me think
um no you just had two pop right into
your head and then you tried to Slough
them off pick one of those
uh I work from home two days a week and
um
I would say that it can be kind of hard
to focus when I'm at home working
so you know you log in and you don't do
anything
I I get what I need to done but I don't
do much past that yeah
uh are you one of those quiet quitters
uh well I'm not sure
don't
um okay so what else that's that's a
light one there's more
um
I would say that
okay well there there is a big one uh I
don't know how comfortable I'd be
sharing it okay that's fine um
I had a uh I I just turned a manuscript
in for a new book and I had a chapter in
it called the biology of Secrets I ended
up pulling out
I ended up cutting that chapter but I
need you to know
um
what you're carrying now will will
destroy you
okay
so I want you to call somebody today
that you can sit down whether that's a
friend whether that's a mentor or
whether that's a professional counselor
um
uh that you can sit down and say hey
I've I'm in over my head
will you commit to that
yeah definitely
think of your body's response in these
moments as just alarm systems trying to
keep you safe
I want you to keep a Notes app open on
your phone or get yourself a journal
something that you carry with you
something small something I don't care
what it is
but I want you to begin to write these
thoughts down when you get that email at
three o'clock and it's like oh crap what
did I do I want you to write that down
or the first thought is you think you
thought you think they found out write
that down and then say what did they
find out
what did they find out
and if there's a couple of things that
would get you sent to jail or get you
fired you need to deal with that
directly quit it knock it off
or at least have the at least have the
uh
uh Integrity to quit to resign and go do
something else
yeah um
because that I'll just leave that there
but I want you to begin to challenge
these things what you're going to find
is most of them are not true
your feelings are strong and loud and
Powerful signals but they're not always
true in fact they they can be rarely
true
um and so I want you to acknowledge them
and feel them write them down look at it
demand evidence from these things you're
writing down and then move on
consciously walk into the middle of that
anxiety
um so let's think of an easy one
um
let's say you used to have a a
pornography addiction let's just
something that's common you used to have
a pornography addiction and you don't
you don't anymore not even a thing like
don't look at it all
and you're married now and your wife
says hey I need to use your computer
real quick and you're instantly your
heart goes starts beating really fast
because you spent 10 years hiding
your computer or you spent 10 years
always clearing your search history and
then going in and clearing the cache all
that stuff right I'm going to do this
I'm gonna do this
and so you're gonna write it down what
is my body scared of oh that's not me
anymore
or hey did you get the cereal out this
morning your wife asks you and your body
sets off into fight or flight because
when you were a kid that question could
get you uh a smack across the side of
your head
and now you're older and you're going to
write it down
this question sent me into Fireflight is
did I get the cereal out the answer is
yes and it's our house it's my house I
did I got the cereal out and she'll
probably go put it away ding dong or
okay
um see if there's enough for me to have
some like something simple right so
let's begin to write these things down
all we're doing is we're teaching our
body we used to not be safe
now we are
and
like all things
especially with anxiety
it's easy to always be pointing your
finger out there out there out there
sometimes
we're doing things that our body's
trying to protect the world from
don't keep secrets
don't keep secrets they'll kill you